[Music]  congratulations in order for the young  ladies from summerlin south little  league their latest victory over arizona  takes them to the little league softball  world series in north carolina next week  as the west region champs we caught up  with some of the players after the win  as you can imagine they are excited  once in a lifetime opportunity that very  few  people that play softball or baseball  have gotten to do there's a hundred  and fifty kids going where there's  millions of kids that  want to go it's just absolutely crazy  like i never imagined that i would be a  part of it  all right ladies their givings begin  august 12th  we are certainly rooting them on the  team is also looking to the community  for some support to cover some travel  costs for that tournament  you can find a link to their gofundme on  our website eightnewsnow.com